citizens of the reject Nation we are here for
what is easily one of my most anticipated shows
of the year we are starting up the Ahsoka Series
so you use a force to leave the like button and
John how are you I so can't wait to see what
this show is like to see what the show is like
but and Michael who literally just got back from
a flight he is our Star Wars expert and didn't
want to start this without him thank you for
readjusting your flight plans I would not miss
it for the world you did like a whole rewatch
whole reread I did a lot of re-watching and a
lot of my first time reading I learned how to
read for this I read that throughout books it
was my first book I ever got through so this
was an exciting thing for me well before we
go into this we got a word from a grand Admiral
sponsor hey guys it's many of you all know I'm
a big fan of G fuel I love me some g-fuel and
here's the thing sometimes when you get re-up
for the brand most of the time they will offer
you a little bit more moolah a little bit more
money because they're like wow you being
getting so many conversions you've been
encouraged to that audience to go get some
more G fuel we're gonna pay you a little bit
more money that's not how it operates around
here what I've decided instead was you don't
need to pay me more money just send me a lot
more G Fuel and so that's exactly what they did
there we go people come in here see and I still
got this much left to fill in for G fuel use our
code rejects to get yourself 20 off select tops
this is all mine I'm not sharing this anymore oh
yeah so I forgot to mention full length Reaction
watch along where you single with your own copy of
Ahsoka series that's going to be available for
super sex we just got our patreon but because
this is the first episode it's available for
the entire public Link in the description box
and pin comments so you can go choose that
option if you prefer let's let's get into it
oh Samurai music boy oh boy
this is refreshing a crawl nice evil Galactic
Empire has fallen and a new Republic has taken it
to its place however Sinister agents are already
at work to undermine the fragile peace a plot is
underway to find the lost Imperial Grand Admiral
thrawn and bring him out of Exile once presumed
Dead rumors are spreading of thrawn's return
which would Galvanize the Imperial remnants
and start another Hua former Jedi Knight Ahsoka
Tano captured one of thrawn's allies and learned
of a secret map which is vital to the enemy's
plans Ahsoka Now searches for the map as her
prisoner Morgan ellsbeth is transported to the
new Republic for trial I'm surprised none of
us did the Clone Wars Voice last time on Star
Wars yes the new Republic Cruiser so Elizabeth
is your prisoner I mean what else are you
gonna do with her after weaponer in a duel
ask them to identify themselves and transmit
their clearance code yes sir yo the music is
great so yeah this is do you know who did it I'm
not sure they're Jedi they say again the signal
clearance code I want to meet these Jedi
oh boy I've got a bad feeling about this
yeah I like how the pacing feels like
it's taking its time already it's just so
cinematic already compared to everything
else I wish it felt more like a cartoon
oh okay row quite a surprise beating Jedi out
here on existence remains a mystery to most
Captain hail uh some slight Qui-Gon Vibes I
don't understand you're no Jedi no they're
not should have surrendered when the Empire
collapsed get RD3 to scan these Impostors
for identification you're all dead to show you
our identification oh boy there's the orange Oh
no you're right about one thing
Captain I'm no Jedi we are no Jedi
it feels like a reversal on a phantom menace
that's exactly it yeah it Rhymes poetry
lady gotta fight lady
foreign
ER hallway whoa oh happy yes
wow what an introduction yeah he's menacing
Morgan
she looks more like a witch of death
Amir more than ever right now she sure
does the Jedi who captured me seeks
the map who is this Jedi Ahsoka Tana
the God's damn right oh boy oh
boy oh boy have a card come on
I just love it it's carrying over that Western
Vibe it does feel like that episode of forest
season 2 was the pilot for this master and
Apprentice part one instead of chapter one love it
where are we Denver Colorado
here we go
the glyphs kind of look like uh
some stuff from fall and Order
foreign yes
awesome awesome
she could just easily use your hands
she's like I'm gonna do this so badass
oh okay the golden snitch
you're a Jedi Ahsoka
getting some World between World Vibes right now
giant boulder is gonna chase her out of there I
know it yeah put put the bag of sand on top oh
I think she just really likes this rock
I've never scratched jealous of a rock
that was actually a really cool
subtle way of using the force
sick
I really love how deliberate this is so
far watching her study the room also after
playing Jedi Survivor for like a thousand hours
as somebody else have to solve a puzzle for once
okay
Fifth Element multi-pass
I love this foreboding music who did this score
it really is that swashbuckling Vibe where
is Omega when you finally find the treasure
already in contact with him I wonder
if she's the one that kept him safe
the crackle of tenants voice
oh here we go hello there
sounds exactly like Kyla us
it doesn't sound exactly like Kayla
give a Droid a cape it is the coolest thing
I have two phallic objects
kick their asses
she just Falls in neck by accident
I don't even waste her time
yes yeah
oh man head turn wow this is like playing
Jedi Survivor yes thump self-destruct
got a blast okay are they gonna blow
this all the ruins yep where are you
great shot holy [__] this looks
great man no you won't keep going oh
damn
nipple chills everywhere
wow damn destroyer of worlds
good thing I arrived when I did watch my
back that is the job of a Jedi Padawan Lana
you have been right where Morgan said it
would be how did you get her to tell the
truth as Morgan wanted to snatch it from you
I didn't follow standard Jedi protocol oh wow
if it still goes by Cold filter
well it sounded like he's going
by fulcrum he's going about
who Yang's going by fulcrum
affirmative 26 out this is already better to be
the Mandalorian season three I'm also excited
to finally have some good portrayal
of the new Republic because it's been
they did not put their dollars to
waste on this one no they did not
visual effects team did an excellent job on
this I mean I feel like I'm watching a movie
she looks awesome general sandula
see you cry I'm afraid we've lost your prisoner
and prepared a briefing to get you caught up it's
like old times I wonder if we're gonna
see the little baby Chase who are they
pose what a freeze perhaps one of them was once a
Jedi possibly huh I'm gonna guess Balin was once a
Jedi and then she was The Apprentice that makes
sense by their age this old man needed a mentor
star map not just any star map this one holds
the secret Morgan's after look at symbol the last
missing Imperial Grand Admiral thrawn which can
get them to Bridger I started hearing whispers of
his return which led me to Morgan thrawn returned
somehow and the secret is held in that map
opportunities during the storm we're having a
little bit of an earthquake right now rolling
hurricane earthquake nothing is certain except
our enemies believe that they know where to look
whoa this reaction is more like
Star Wars at everything yeah
Disney plus plus you know
who could help you with this
I do go to Sabine I'm not sure she'll want to help
she'll do it make her for Ezra
oh gosh I still can't believe
that this is real life
baby look at it go it's a true Metropolis now
dude no way they got her did they get him to
play a rider again oh my goodness in recognition
courage
tell me he's playing Ryder here
to say a few words is one of
those Rebel leaders Commander Sabine
Wren or the mural behind the man yo
oh this feels like Rebels
Sabine ran finder now and Destroyer
oh my gosh that's gnarly it was brought to life
all right for those that don't know Sabine wren
this is a great introduction right here
that is awesome oh man they
literally brought the bridge to life
feels like the opening of
that JJ Abram Star Trek movie
siberius Kirk Governor's
Daddy's looking for you oh yeah
are you missing the ceremony oh that was today
man amazing I can't believe they brought
this to life well they spared no expense
her helmet what is this song I
think it's new Commander Stand Down
is she gonna stop nope nope
Stand Down she's not stopping
she's crazy doesn't even look
like her pulse is racing whoa
boy boy oh boy wow
recognized game
this must be that punk band
from uh the Visions episode
we'll see a lost wolf in here oh God I hope so
new merchandise unlocked
I already got mine on pre-order
everyone's looking to adopt a
cat or fostering five right now
a nice little subtle it's interesting
how she's become like a full-on like
there's a dissonance she's recluse
well I can't imagine it'd be easier
for her to confront what happened
on Mandalore after her friends
damn they look real animatronic
more than the others I need I need you to
understand you left her a separate recording
we've been through a lot grew up together
in this Rebellion we're not really family
but you're like a sister to me that's a change of
town now I won't be there to help you
I'm counting on you to see this through
May the force be with you May the force be with
you see what through I mean I imagine it hoping
to get back to Mandalore that didn't quite pan
out and imagine her whole family was killed
she reminds me of just
about everybody I know in LA
she has a lot of presents though man
an ancient temple built by my ancestors
who the ninth sisters of death the night sisters
they confirmed it you're a witch yes she is burner
a Survivor yeah the Jedi has the map or it
was vaporized no she hasn't what if she does
you're lucky luck has nothing to do with it Fate
has decided our next moon then it's lucky fate
would do that send this one to the planet lothal
retrieve it she can anticipate that Ahsoka would
go to Sabine ahsokitano's former Apprentice
is on the foul you're looking for Sabine wren
he knows a little too much but how I
mean maybe he knew Ahsoka when he was
like once part of the Jedi Order
yeah or a young lane or something
this is very translator
was it just a dream is she connecting via the
force it was heavily implied that she was force
sensitive if you're gonna piss off the World
by saying that I mean to wield the darksaber
the way she did to be The Apprentice of Ahsoka
Tana maybe she might be this is an interesting
parallel because Ahsoka and Sabine you know master
and Apprentice but Bale and his master they like
get along and there's such a distance between
these two so it is telling a parallel between them
you missed the ceremony was that yesterday my
mind I missed Sabine everyone was there this
makes me so happy I know hello who Yang still in
one piece oh yes still 75 original pounds super
man looking at each other
I think there is some additional stuff that we
might not know about between these two of course
we'll handle the tension you're going to want
to hear what she has to say it's cool that he
gets to play two live-action characters now in
the Star Wars show that's pretty amazing right
this music is so transported
it is quite moving I gotta say
it really does help bolster the visual
language I think I know how to find Ezra who
chives
to hear some of that familiar
Star Wars Tunes Hope Rising
when at the end of rebels she arrived at the
White staff that's already common gone and some
things happened after that I'm pretty sure that's
what's going on yeah well you thought this might
have been an in-between then I thought this
might have been that exact moment and just
a little retcon and how they do it oh Chopper
where did you find this in a world named Arcana
it was a stronghold for the witches
of dothamir oh wow we're getting so
much to happen here you have the
artist guy tell me what you see
who there's such tension between them
where do you call home these days
this ship serves me fine the bed with who yang
lightsabers aren't the only thing he can build
you never made things easy for me Master oh
clarify what that means there is
nothing easy about being a Jedi
so was training her to be a jet and I should
have made a good one she just blocked herself
got destroyed during her training I think she
blocks herself off from the force but from her
stubbornness and I think by the end of the show
the force will be Unleashed good can I take this
where are you going that's not good
somewhere I can think more clearly
I'm not sure that's a good
idea that's a terrible idea
why this isn't just about finding Ezra it's about
preventing Another War you think I don't know that
map stays here
it's not gonna stay okay
I love that Ahsoka has to deal with an apprentice
who is just as stubborn frustrated as she was
can't hold a mirror to herself I think sometimes
it's harder to train the one that's so similar
to you construction and overall design are
executed exactly the way I taught youngings to
build a lightsaber oh [__] in the last 500
years I've only known one student who built
a saber such as this damn he disappeared
at the end of the Clone Wars as many Jedi
Order 66 Survivor master and an apprentice it
would be my assumption he took on an apprentice
after that interesting that's interesting because
they're not exactly Sith some type of in between
it's not a gray Jedi every time we
say gray Jedi something awful happens
let's get this video dive bombed no [__]
dude they're gonna go right after Sabine
she would totally lose that fight oh this is gonna
be like uh Qui-Gon on his way back to
the ship on Tatooine with Darth Maul
hello literally exactly like it probe Droid
and everything it is poetry I mean filoni
loves Phantom Menace he sure does this is the
shot with Darth exactly the same thing yeah
whoa good reveal dang I love how storyboarded
this feels you can really almost like
animation yeah every shot is composed
it's interesting that the way they've
composed this because even if you
haven't seen Rebels I think they do that
like John Wick hinting at history thing
where you can still like kind of keep
up um right clearly yeah all right yeah
okay cool she took the map
off the ship when I explicitly told her not
to come on a Circa but you and I both know
yep she's still just a
stubborn and bullish as ever
give it Eight Episodes things didn't
turn out the way either of us wanted
this is not gonna go the way you think
too soon it's always too soon for the end
of the Clone Wars I walked away from him
I was watching the whole Jedi Order yeah no oh you
look so sad just like I walked away from Sabine
you have commitment problems sometimes even
the right reasons have the wrong consequences
poignant Ends don't justify the means I
feel like she has every reason to fear
miss training an apprentice after her
master became you know hey there you go
it's a Rubik's Cube oh
and it has three faces oh sick
wow they're doing this all in one shot that
is so that is so cool yeah awesome cool
yo oh and this is right when that
girl's gonna show up actually whoa
he's right there interestingly enough that
looked like a different galaxy
a galaxies are farther away yeah
take it we're gonna take the loath cat
hey sneaky
kick its ass
how do your elbows handle this
smash against metal oh God oh God
oh smart oh yeah
they're still talking helmet
helmet do it no lightsaber yo yeah
she's gonna totally lose
this fight though we've been
just gonna she's gonna get owned
it feels like a samurai duel
what about Star Wars has it anyways oh all right
this fight does feel kind of like Kendo like a
felony doesn't adopt the pretty cool fighting
oh she is they're both just trying to
study each other oh dang oh here it is okay
ah she's just toying with
Sabine that's exactly it yeah
dude oh so it was gonna happen right now
whoa so many badass cross saber shots there
I see them this is literally Phantom Menace
I feel like sabine's gonna get stabbed
if you lose a limb oh come on
whoa
wow and then they killed off Sabine wren
did not return somehow oh
it's very present well done Dana e gloverman Kevin
keiner he did uh Rebels sure did Wowie that makes
a lot of sense oh it's the pergil so the first
time in a long time that Star Wars visual effects
in television is doesn't feel like it's just on
a volume that's exactly it now this felt I was
I was immersed yeah like they probably did do
a lot of volume but they sold it really well
oh yeah with physical elements yeah I I genuinely
love that I was in love with that it was he played
writer right yeah okay that's so cool if you got
okay for you guys who don't know Clancy Brown
played writer in Star Wars Rebels and to see him
get to actually as everyone else has been recast
right everyone else yeah everyone and Chopper and
Chopper but to see him it pop back up and after he
already was in uh Mandalorian as as uh it was in
that Bill Burr episode as one of the villains and
I think that was the Rick Family episode of season
one wow that was a great episode yeah uh and
um yeah he's one of the most prolific voice actors
out there he's just a great like real life actor
too so it's so cool to see him actually yeah
that translated so well uh and there's just so
many beautiful little touches the time spent on
lethal and just seeing that come to life I mean
it really was they captured it perfectly
yeah I loved how meditative this was and
and how like it was emotional yet cold you know
and and I think they're gonna be arcing into
something that does feel either more hopeful
or more harrowing like you really don't know
which direction will go because it's a it's
supposed to be setting up some stuff right uh
for whatever that filoni crossover the felony
verse which is what this is and this is the
first time felony got to actually Helm the pilot
like literally setting the stage for everything
that's to come and while I thought that episode of
Mandalorian season two which reintroduced Ahsoka
it that felt like the backdoor pilot for
this in every way concerning that you
got Elizabeth you're picking up with right away
the confirmation that she's a witch of dathomir
um who if you guys like play Jedi fall in
order or you know obviously Clone Wars you'd
be familiar with her the plan where Darth Maul is
from yeah and um then and Savage Savage Ventress
Opress no savage oh wait no waitress Adventures
yeah yeah oh Savage yeah I got my [__] names
the ill-fated brother the brother of all yeah
um yeah are they really a massage yeah that's
where I got confused here yeah a lot of names
out there there are a couple names in Star Wars
um but I loved it man uh I I thought this was
the right tone and this is what uh I I hoped it
would be I do wonder if some people might find
it boring though you know if they're I I think
there can be a bit of a disc because it's weird
I mean I'm excited to hear what you think because
um he doesn't care what I think I know it's just
I think it'll be really easy for us to get wrapped
up in like Rebels talking all that stuff so uh
whereas if you a lot of people didn't see Rebels
I wonder if they'll be felt that
they'll be left at a distance you know
um but would you so yeah what'd
you think so far Michael well
interestingly enough I feel like these first
two episodes are likely going to be the most
of the feeding that like the love of rebels
and and I think some of the later episodes
particular as particularly I mean when Ahsoka
even when her master was referenced the way
her face changed like Anakin's Force ghost is
around at this point right have they talked have
they had that conversation yet I mean I think
there's going to be a lot of unpacking there
um and for me like having just finished the thrawn
books and the comics there is something that like
Rebels fans are I don't think even prepared for
unless they've read the books and admittedly
even having read the books I don't think I'm
prepared for what they have cooking up here
um but in terms of pace I'm glad this was a slow
burn I mean I was I was on the edge of my seat
the entire time it felt genuinely cinematic which
is something that Star Wars television there was
some episodes of the Mandalorian that knocked that
out of the park and other episodes where I'm like
what is lizzo doing here yeah um certainly not
forcing anybody out of their comfort zone yeah
I'll tell you that much yeah but I loved it and
uh honestly I hate that we're even talking right
now because I want to watch The Next Step I
know yeah I know people are just like get to
the next one they released they released two
for a reason yeah yeah yeah you're like oh
you're that's why I'm trying not to become a
prognosticator for what's going to come next
because I'm like what's the point we're gonna
watch the second episode then we prognosticated
a good ass vocab word damn that's good that's
a t word yeah yeah no I mean I looked it up
beforehand so I could use it in this video
because of every video I've touched Lord
for every video it'll be like just implement it
somehow hey that's a good technique you'll have
at least 365 new words at the end of the year
uh no I mean this was really thrilling like
like having only a mild amount of familiarity
with what Rebels is tone wise and Ensemble wise
and stuff like this gave me the joys of both
how do I how do I put it this this felt like
the sort of fun adventure that you get from a
Mandalorian but with like the focus that a lot
of people complain is missing from that and I
feel like this also everybody points to and or
is like the second coming of Star Wars in a lot
of ways it's certainly earns that argument but
I thought this did nicely to pull the kind of
quiet character Nuance from Andor and then put
it in something that still feels like it's
going to be propulsive and about Adventure
um but also contained within just a lot of
character relationships and growth and frictions
and history over time and yeah not having all
of that context I could feel it all through
the performances and I think it was really smart
for them to give you so many moments and scenes
to introduce each character to put them in their
element to show them breaking things down or being
rebellious or whatever it is kind of drawing the
spirits like everybody is very clear at the moment
to me even though we haven't spent time with like
the classic Rebels Ensemble all together much yet
um yeah this had a constant sense of momentum
and tension the Sith characters or the you know
in between Jedi Sith whatever these new Balin
and Co are gonna be their lightsabers are orange
yeah so there's something in between yeah what
does it mean it is I'll tell you what it means
this is the connective tissue between all of
it and I feel like an orange is the color and
orange is the color of connective tissue have
you ever cut somebody open before no uh come
on uh I it's all orange it is it's disgusting
um I am particularly eager and excited to see
how like everything that we've seen so far in
just one episode is what I think we were all
praying for when the force awakens came out we
wanted that like questionable what happens when
the Jedi Order is no more is there something in
between we wanted to be able to tap into the the
mystical nature of the force have that connective
tissue to the prequels to the original trilogy but
also set up something big and exciting and the
most important part and what I think they failed
at in the sequel Trilogy is something original
something different and like Obi-Wan too I feel
like you have that hope of like you know here
is what what do you do in the No Man's Land
Between You Know One establishment in another
one order and another and we didn't really
rise quite to that occasion I agree yeah yeah
there's a nice mystery and suspense to this
and there's I thought what was really smart I
think it's really really smart uh to have this
established dynamic between Ahsoka and Sabine that
way you can give a character Arc especially for a
variety of factors yeah one being that when Ahsoka
was reintroduced in live action with Mandalorian
and her little parents and book of Boba Fett that
but that portrayal is someone who's just so wise
and sage and she's got everything under control
yeah yeah exactly a little too perfect exactly
which is great for like in a an appearance a guest
star appearance but if she's going to be the lead
you need to uh throw her into something where
they can be an emotional obstacle a hurdle for
her to overcome and for it to be something that
is mirroring her past trajectory of someone who
was stubborn and difficult to deal with and then
her even acknowledging like hey I abandoned stuff
you know I I left I got disillusioned by the Jedi
Order I left that behind yeah I mean there's a
lot of context there that I love how they they're
smart in the way they do it because there's such a
story line in the Clone Wars of why she left the
Jedi Order that when you watch it it's it's not
like she just left the Jedi Order it was so it is
is the whole thing like being framed and all this
stuff I mean or left her yeah exactly there's
this whole thing to it so it's not just she
left the Jedi order but they didn't have to make
a brief because they don't have time to dive into
all that [__] right the level of responsibility
though that must be on her shoulders I mean even
if you don't watch all the Clone Wars to watch
the final two seasons and particularly how they
connect ahsoka's final Arc there yeah I mean she's
living with a heavy burden right and a lot of this
is about also not repeating the sins of the not
repeating the mistakes from the past that she's
trying to do so they've established a good Arc
for her to go down and then of course for Sabine
as well and I did yeah because she's a really
complex character too I thought she should have
been the leader of rebels I mean well yeah she she
should have been and I think towards the end she
was getting there um but you have to consider the
fact that like she created a weapon that played
a big role in the destruction of her people like
she has not had an easy go of it based upon where
we are in the timeline Mandalore is gone which
means her family's been vaporized exactly like
um I didn't even think about that
and and I I think that's probably
the other thing is if she became ahsoka's
Apprentice she would have been pretty old at
the time to become an apprentice and historically
speaking that doesn't always work out the way you
want it to all the rules are thrown out the
window at this point man well uh no I I don't
I don't disagree with that but it comes with its
own set of challenges um but either way there's
only one real way to figure out what happens
next yeah and that's to like And subscribe
more so than watching the next episode like
And subscribe yeah click the notification Bell
um yeah alrighty guys well I thought
uh this was excellent and I I hope that
people latch onto the show um especially
if you're not familiar with I don't feel
I don't get the impression you need to I
think it's easy to feel lost like there
I can imagine there will still be that
camp that's like but I think that's good
and it does I think increase the motivation
probably for then people if they do latch onto
this to go check out the extended media because
then they will have instead of feeling overwhelmed
by like there's so many seasons and so many
characters I have like a point of reference now
to go and look for in those pieces but they don't
craft the dialogue in a way that's like wink you
know well no it still sounds very lived in and
this is the exchange that they would have with
each other it does it's not just Exposition City
it's not just Easter egg city either one somebody
pointed out that in the advertising they haven't
leaned at all on any of the animated footage
so they're not telling they're not cueing the
audience like you gotta go familiarize yourself
with that otherwise you're not gonna get this at
all but it doesn't like again like from outside a
little bit of that giant well sure there are
definitely going to be things that go over
your head but those things don't feel like you're
being left out of the club or like you know you're
lesser for not knowing but if if you have watched
other live-action Star Wars at this point you know
a majority of the people on that mural yeah
you know with the exception of Kanan and Ezra
you don't think Force ghost Canyon will show up no
how would he have learned to become a Force ghost
what do you mean you have to learn to become
that's not how the force works that matters
you could throw it out the window at this
point had to well for he wasn't able to get
like a physical form at first he could have
learned something that's a mumbo jumbo into
a ghost in a few years or he's in the
wolf right he isn't a wolf he's in the
wall that I that I believe mostly because
Dave filoni has a thing for wolves well
he's got one of those wolf t-shirts wolf
just shows up you're just like I'm doom
man I remember just being on the internet trying
to figure out what the hell was going on with
those wolves when I was watching Rebels I hope it
saves the day again all right let's watch second
episode let's do it let's do it all right thanks
guys for being here and um yeah let's get to it